more faith that that something will
happen in an Obama administration I mean
yeah Bush was also product of prep
schools and an Ivy League education and
his aw shucks on just a kicker from
Texas played well but he had every
advantage in the world silver spoon
father a president grandfather very
powerful if that's not elitism I don't
know it is well I only paint people that
who I know who are friends or people I'd
like to get to know better or you know
whatever I don't paint and I always work
for my own photographs and I had
photographed President Clinton between
his first and second administration to
do something as a fundraiser for his
reelection and I photographed him in the
Oval Office and whatever and I and over
his two terms I think I was probably in
the White House maybe eight or ten times
for various things for I worked on
various committees and on things that
had to do with the arts and also health
issues and
the handicapped and things like that I
did work for the embassies Anna and the
Clintons gave me a very nice dinner when
I did that and I got the National Medal
of the Arts from President Clinton so
you know there were a number of you know
I guess I felt like an fo be in a friend
of Bill and afraid of Hillary's worked
for her raised a lot of money for her
senatorial election and I did admire
them very much and I think they were you
know incredibly important for our
society think Quentin is certainly one
of the best presidents of my lifetime on
and I think so the Hillary has been a
very effective senator and looking
forward to what she does a state and I
hope that eventually she may end up on
the Supreme Court something like that up
Obama were to think of her